we've talked before about the problem
that we have in political discourse when
one side doesn't accept facts it is a
real impediment to being able to make
progress and have good-faith debate
about any issue that we find important
and we're seeing that now front and
center with the Ukraine Fiasco where
only 40 percent of Republicans 40
percent of Republicans believe that
Donald Trump spoke to the Ukrainian
president about Joe Biden on the phone
remember Donald Trump is admitted to
this that bogus transcript which was
actually a memo sort of a truncated
summary of the call includes a
discussion of Joe Biden between Donald
Trump and the Ukrainian president
Ukrainian presidents so let's take a
step back and think about opinion versus
fact if you poll people about something
like their opinion on gay marriage it is
far more reasonable that you would have
very different perspectives from
Democrats Republicans and independents
now for me I think that the opinion on
gay marriage there's only one right
opinion on gay marriage but okay this is
a matter of opinion and you would expect
more difference in people's opinion on
gay marriage but when Monmouth
University Polling Institute asked
people do you believe that Donald Trump
spoke about Joe Biden on that phone call
with the Ukrainian president almost all
Democrats believed that that is
something that was discussed about 60%
of independents believed that it was
something that was discussed but only
40% of Republicans believed it Donald
Trump admitted that they discussed this
on the call not only did Trump admit it
when asked but the truncated transcript
their memo that the White House released
also includes the mention of Biden so
what do we do what do we do when one
side won't even accept inconvenient but
verified facts that their own leader
gives to them now of course there's the
separate question of whether Donald
Trump extorted or tried to extort
Ukraine and there's lots of other
questions but Trump admitted that they
spoke about Biden and 60% of Republicans
either don't believe it or don't know
now there are some possible questions
about this poll it was conducted during
a period mostly after the transcript or
memo was released but there was one
polling day in there that was before it
was released some people may just not
have seen the new
about that yet but the trend is very
clear if they don't like the facts they
pretend they don't exist and this makes
it difficult or even impossible to
advance serious conversations about what
has to be done it's similar with climate
change where there are real serious
conversations about what policies should
we have what degree of government
involvement should there be in climate
change in dealing with that what about
personal responsibility when dealing
with climate change whatever question
you want to talk about we can't even get
on the same page about what the facts
are because some large portion of the
American right-wing just refuses to
accept the facts on climate change we
can't possibly fix anything or even
discuss it in good faith if one side
doesn't accept the facts and sadly this
is how I end up back at we need to get
around them to win we don't we can't try
to win with them a conversation about
how to proceed with Trump or about the
economy or about who to vote for in 2020
or about tariffs these conversations are
pointless as ways to engage with people
about making change in 2020 if they
won't even accept basic facts including
ones that their Dear Leader gives them
the short answer is you can't
and you shouldn't and we don't need to
as the upside I don't want to be a
broken record again but half the country
doesn't vote meaning you don't have to
go out and find people and convince them
that voting for Trump is a bad idea
that's not necessary to win this you
just need to find people who are already
on our side and just explain to them the
importance of voting and that is much
easier to do it's still not easy I've
met people who don't vote and it's it's
not easy to convince them that they
should be voting but it is easier than
convincing someone who won't even
believe Trump when Trump says we talked
about Joe Biden on the Ukrainian
president phone call and I don't even
think that we should bother doing it